what's your favorite Star Wars character
of all time and go this is your weekend
ticket if you're looking to see one
movie this weekend by yourself then solo
is the solo solo movie you should see
it's probably better to see it with
friends but then the solo joke wouldn't
have worked so the much-anticipated hon
centric chapter of the Star Wars saga
will introduce Chewbacca and Lando
chronologically this movie takes place
after episode 3 Revenge of the Sith and
before both the animated Star Wars
rebels series and rogue one a Star Wars
story I was excited about the
relationships in this story because it
defines Han Solo really as a character
and it gives that character a chance to
to you know reveal something of himself
entertain us in different ways you're
surrounded this movie is for you if you
love Star Wars if you like Star Wars or
even if you've never heard the phrase
Star Wars before in your life
in which case happy birthday seeing as
you were born today the last three Star
Wars films did pretty well for
themselves so Solo has his work cut out
for him domestically the last Jedi
grossed 620 million wrote one grossed
532 million and the force awakens
grossed 936 million and that is your
weekend ticket check back next week for
Johnny Knoxville's action point
[Music]